bonjour m'appelle régis henry je suis
gérant de la sarl vie
spécialisé dans les automatismes de
portails systèmes de contrôle d'accès
l'entreprise existe 2
bientôt depuis huit ans
et vraiment spécialisés dans la partie
automatisation de portail est
essentiellement sur la partie
résidentielle donc tout ce qui est
immeuble immeubles collectifs
d'habitation au delà des automatismes
que l'on sait tous qui contrôle d'accès
comme sur le panneau que vous avez
derrière moi interphonie digicode tout
ce qui concerne la périphérie du
bâtiment pour pouvoir accéder à
l'intérieur la sécurité du bâtiment
c'est des métiers qui qui évoluent avec
les technologies actuelles
et les systèmes informatiques appropriés
l'effectif de bip est composé de huit
personnes quatre techniciens une
assistante de direction ange qui a en
charge du sav d'entreprise une
secrétaire on accueil téléphonique et
physique un assistant de production et
qui à lui en charge les achats de
l'entreprise et un commercial
de trouver un technicien ou des
personnes qui ont des qualifications
dans le secteur de l'automatisme et des
contrôles d'accès alors les profils sont
généralement tournés vers des bep bac
pro ou bts
électronique ou électrotechnique
sur le recrutement
nous préférons avoir des gens qualifiés
donc
c'est un métier où il n'ya pas de
formation appropriée donc la plupart des
gens se forment sur le sur le cas et
nous mêmes pour monde et les techniciens
anneaux à notre spécificité des
personnes qui ont déjà de l'expérience
et un savoir faire dans ce domaine
ont déjà
un grand avantage le type de contrat que
nous proposons
et plus
un contrat en cdd avec une
une évolution
dans la mesure où notre spécificité est
quand même
et quand même assez particulière les
automatismes contrôle d'accès et
détermine en règle générale sur un
contrat à durée indéterminée
le technicien automatismes et contrôle
d'accès doit maîtriser les connaissances
élémentaires en électricité et en
électrotechnique
concevoir et mettre en place des
systèmes complexes
réaliser un diagnostic des causes de
défaillance
faire preuve d'un bon contact clientèle
un petit conseil pour les personnes
intéressées
j'ai reçu une demande hier
c'était très bien formulé la personne à
a pris soin de faire un cv et une
demande qui est vraiment très attrayante
donc je vais vraiment prendre note de
cette demande et rappeler cette personne
qui déjà à a beaucoup de choses
intéressantes à me tire fort 6 cv donc
n'hésitez pas à pour vous faire valoir
vos compétences à mettre le maximum dans
ce petit papier qui est quand même votre
image